some eight billion journeys are made by
train every year a big shake-up could be
on the way by the fourth wave a package
passenger services will be thrown open
to competition and new rules aimed to
make a clear separation between the
ownership of rail infrastructure and the
operation of services liberalisation FAL
more quelque chose de vital Lisa V
schism monopolistic source vorskla Jose
inside Parliament many MEP is argue that
liberalisation will be a good footprint
for European rail network by breaking up
monopolies opening up the marketplace
competition and delivering better
customer service we have an open access
on the freight rail transport in 2007
and all those countries who had opened
the network before this state their big
success for example United Kingdom sixty
percent plus on freight on rail so you
can see the market opening is good for
the rebels is a different story trade
unions are happy for them liberalisation
means an end to job security somewhere
celeb to you foolish you know who live
washer it for too long the UK was one of
only a few EU countries to favor full
liberalisation but the success of his
privatization has been a mixed bag
because of underinvestment
infrastructure a big change under the
new legislation is decoupling of train
management from infrastructure to bring
about greater financial transparency and
remove barriers on wednesday all
dossiers other package passed the vote
in the chamber but for those who had
favored sweeping change they were left a
little bit short change larger the most
important parts of the railway will
remain in the hands of the incumbent
operators and those operators can only
provide services which today already
customers say they don't feel satisfied
with it's true that the proposals I made
with the Transport Committee have been
watered down a little bit most important
is that we achieve the good framework in
which competition could occur in future
safeguarding qualitative public services
and at the same time also safeguarding
let's say the social rights of the
workers which is also an important point